so I'll start with the basics this talk
is called from past import print
statement it is subtitled a data is
trajection of Python 2 verses 3 today is
Saturday March 11 2016 and we're at PI
data Amsterdam so I'll get started hi
I'm James
hi I'm James very good if you like this
talk you can now follow me on key bass
at D UTC and also there may be something
wrong with you because this is probably
one of the worst talks I've ever given
and I haven't even given it yet
so I'll start off why D UTC it stands
for don't use this code it's a
disclaimer so anything I show you in
this talk just remember don't use this
code some people think it's Dutch and I
have a sticky H key on my keyboard but
that's not what it is however I will say
I put in close to the bare minimum
effort in putting this talk together
including the bare minimum effort in
learning about the culture of this
beautiful country so I spent about three
minutes googling about Dutch culture and
I found some interesting things out I
found that we might have some things in
common for example I found this one
webpage among the first three hits on
Google because I didn't really want to
go any further about Dutch humor and
here's some phrases I pulled from that
the Dutch have a sense of humor that
relishes misshapen mayhem a whiff of
naughtiness and the violation of the odd
taboo are common ingredients for a good
laugh the more refined brands of Dutch
humor are dry delight and absurdity and
in turning social values topsy-turvy and
I thought that's kind of similar to some
of the talks I've given and past in fact
I counted and I've given a lot of pie
data talks in past this is the 13th pie
that event I will speak at and the 17th
pie that I talk I will give I've spoken
at pie dad in New York four times pie
Gattaca Silicon Valley twice and PI data
Boston I gave three talks they only had
one of those events
I spoke into PI out of London twice pi
that of Berlin once pied out of Dallas
PI that a Seattle PI data Amsterdam
that's where we are right now and it
turns out I'm also the vice president of
programming at num focus it turns out
when they say vice-president of
programming they don't mean programming
as in writing programs they mean holding
events because come on I'm wearing a
suit I obviously can't code it also it
also happens that there may or may not
be some coincidence between my ability
to give so many talks at so many PI that
events and also being in charge of the
speaker selection committee who knows
that's the way things work in this world
I'll tell you though that most of my
talks are intended to be avant-garde and
this is a term that I choose somewhat
carefully if you were to spend the bare
minimum amount of time trying to figure
out what Alvin card means you might go
to Wikipedia and you pull out a couple
of phrases such as experimental or
innovative or pushes the boundaries of
what is accepted as the norm or the
status quo so I'll give you a demo of
something that I did last year that I
thought was interesting when I first
came up with it and I've gotten somewhat
bored I have since I call it our watch
now unfortunately there's not a lot of
there's not a lot of Wi-Fi in this room
here so I can't show you how ridiculous
this is but just imagine I took a bear
Python 3 5 oh install haven't done
anything to it and I pip installed one
module do TCR watch so if you have
Python 3 500 running on your computer
right now you can pip install D UTC - or
watch and you can use my module let's
see what that module does let me start
my Python terminal I have a module
called our watch and then I can import
from sis two things set our watch and
get our watch I wonder what these do
let's look at the help text the help
text forget our watch says it gets the
target set what sistar or watch it
doesn't really make a lot of sense let's
look at help of set our watch oh you can
set read watches for specified objects
so what i did was i implemented read
watches in the python and the c python
interpreter
what's a read watch let's say I have a
variable X and every time somebody
accesses looks at that variable X I want
to trigger some callback I want to look
at that this is a very common thing that
we do in debuggers like gdb for
languages like C so I might say set an
or watch or let's create a function that
takes a frame and an object and just
says I saw some object at some frame and
just returns the object and then I'll
set a read watch on this object and I'll
call this function so every time I look
at this object it calls that function
and if I have another function that
maybe returns another function this is
nothing too fancy and I say H of X you
can see a trigger twice if I
say G of X the triggered three times
every time somebody looks at this
variable you trigger now this kind of
looks like it might be useful but trust
me it's not intended to be useful its
intended to shock you because it turns
out that read watches are a generalized
form for a lot of things such as
pointers such as lazy evaluation and
I'll show you my favorite thing that you
can do with this you notice when I set
our watch I gave it a dictionary well I
could give it any collection type so let
me from collections I'll import default
dict and I'll create my watch function
like this I'll say if the object I'm
looking at is an integer and it's
between 0 and 10 just return oops we
wrote that wrong let's try that one more
time just return that and let's just do
this well set a read watch so that every
time any variable has ever looked it
calls this callback and now I broke math
and Python so one plus one is now four
two plus two is now eight x equals ten x
times 2 is 40 whoa what's going on here
and you can do some really wild and
crazy things
why is x times two equal 40 because the
two gets changed but the X doesn't
because you can see that you can
generalize a lot of things with this and
so this is something that you could do
to really provoke somebody that you work
with in case
you just want to have a little bit of
fun and you can see what I mean by
avant-garde now one question that you
might have is how because this might
actually seem very useful in fact I
thought this was something that could be
very useful let's say that you're
writing a Python IDE you're PyCharm one
of the other many people who are writing
Python IDs and you say I want to have a
debugger and I want to have the best
Python debugger that can do things that
no other debugger can do that PDB can't
even touch and read watches would be an
incredibly useful thing to have in a
debugger because if you have some single
data item in a huge pipeline and you
want to figure out why that one data
item is throwing errors in some complex
part of the pipeline you just put a read
watching you see oh who's accessing and
looking at this data this is something
that we do in gdb with Hardware read
watches all the time but I want to show
you how I did this and and you'll see
why this matters so the way I did this
was I went into the C Python interpreter
and I found where you push or pop
something from the stack and I just put
a hook on that so every time a variable
gets pushed or popped to the stack you
have a place to put a call back and you
can have a read watch it's pretty much
what a read watch would be but the neat
thing is I showed you I was able to pip
install this onto pure Python 3 five-oh
so how on earth do you pip install
patches to the C Python interpreter it
turns out it's really easy a while back
I came up with this thing it's very very
simple and it's so simple that I'm
actually gotten bored of it but what I
do is when you pip install the module
when you load the module it goes into
the running C Python interpreter it
finds where your C eval you rather your
PI eval eval frame X loop is and it just
patches it it puts a trampoline so it
jumps over to mine which means with this
technique you can generalize the
installation of arbitrary manipulations
to a C Python runtime and I've used this
in order to add things like ast literals
are kind of lazy a kind of eager
evaluation to Python and the demo that
I'm going to show you in just a minute
but you can see it's kind of wild and
this is not an approach that you'd ever
want to do you never want to assembly
patches see Python interpreter
but it's something that actually works
fairly well in practice it works on all
the systems I've tried that are not
Windows because on Windows things work a
little bit differently but Mac and OSX
sorry on OSX and Linux on a see Python
interpreter it's a pretty easy technique
I found other ways to generalize the
technique in case you're not able to for
example
find references to the parts you want to
overwrite so it turns out on Linux you
have a proc file system and you can
write through the proc file system but I
don't have time to get into that in this
talk
the unfortunate thing is when I showed
this to people nobody care and in fact I
can see the faces of you right now and
none of you care either and it was
really depressing me because I was like
wow this is something this is the
wildest craziest worst thing I've ever
done and people were just like okay can
I see another talk by Andy Mueller on
scikit-learn that's what people care
about and I guess maybe I'm at a PI that
event so people care about things that
are PI data related but this is
something that I was interested but I
will tell you the one thing that people
really did care about and one talk that
I gave the strongest reaction I've ever
gotten from any talk I've ever given was
a result of a tiny throwaway line a
single line that I uttered on stage I
said the Python core developers are
focusing their attention on Python 3
after I gave a talk where I said that
one line I was her aimed in a bar for an
hour and a half by a gentleman who was
offended by the notion that he had to
move his code to Python 3 and he kept
arguing with you kept saying I don't
want to go to Python 3 and he felt so
incredibly passionate about it and I
just said well you know this is the way
it is and I'm not part of that political
sphere I'm not a Python core developer
I'm just a hacker who does my stuff on
the side so you know what I don't care I
don't care about Python 2 versus Python
3 there's there's parts about Python - I
don't like there's definitely parts
about Python 3 that I don't think are
that good but you know in the end these
are both tools I enjoy using them and I
don't feel like I have a political stake
in the matter however I'll tell you who
really does care the people on Hacker
News really care about Python 3 and they
don't like it at all
and I don't know why that is but I'll
show you one common thing I've seen here
a couple of snippets I got from about
five minutes of searching hacker news
Python 3 somebody says I was at Euro
Python 2 2006 when Guido announced the
print statement was getting axed it was
a bit of a shock to me
I miss prints as a statement especially
when I try to debug fast and dummy
scripts normally I would agree with you
but one of the epic changes between
Python 2 and 3 was a change of print
from a statement to a function if
someone would make a python 2.8 I
would pay for it by the way I offered to
make a Python 2.8 to this person and
they never responded but I really did if
you look one comment down that's me and
they said finally this Python super date
needs to have a print statement and I
like this one the best you know we have
print another print and you can see one
is horriffic to some people and the
other one isn't Temperance so let me
show you a demo we all work with some
person who's like really trying too hard
to please people who aren't in their
immediate vicinity so we've all worked
with somebody who in a Python to
interpreter there's a Python to
interpreter puts before they write any
code at the very top from future import
print state print function right because
you know if we have print here as a
statement they do this and now the only
time we can use print is as a function
and if we try and use it as a statement
it barks at us and says invalid syntax
and it's the first thing they write
because I really really want to impress
somebody that they're so gung-ho about
Python 3
I like Python 3 I use Python 3 but I'm
not that gung-ho about it so I thought
wouldn't it be neat to do this here we
have a Python 3 interpreter and we have
print as a function what if we said from
past import print statements now it's a
little bit ugly because I actually wrote
this code starting from so I was
supposed to be here at 10 a.m. yesterday
my flight was delayed 9 hours and I was
planning to write my talk on the flight
and it didn't quite work out so I wrote
this hack from 1 a.m. to 5 a.m. this
morning so it's not exactly perfect but
I can do this it's now way it's not a
statement again oops so now I returned
print as a statement did Python language
how about that and unfortunately a
couple of things don't work so you know
in print you have the two angle brackets
that style there's no way to really make
that work with the way I did this and
you kept the trailing comma with the
print statement it says suppress the
newline there's no way to make that work
either but it's PIP installable
and if you give me a maybe another
evening I can get rid of the dollar
signs but what you can see is you put
dollar signs around prints and now it's
a statement again from past import print
statement how about that and maybe
that'll make those people on Hacker News
finally finally a little bit less upset
about Python 3 but the real thing that I
like about this is the question of how
does it work
one of the first C Python hacks that I
ever released the wild was called did
you mean and I'd seen a post on hacker
news about somebody who wrote this did
you mean in Ruby and they just overrode
like method missing and every time you
type miss type of method it suggested
the right one and I said could you do
some Python and I was able to it in
Python it's on github as well but I
tried to find the most perverse
impossible to guess way to do it and
it's a really wild way to do the
approach and you'll see the same thing
here in order to get the print function
to work what I did this is my past
module all it does is it reaches up in
one inspect frame and it replaces your
normal print function with my print
function here and that seems fairly
innocuous except in order to do that
what I did was I rewrote the Python
grammar so you can add arbitrate syntax
extensions so you want new syntax in
Python you can just add it you can add
arbitrary syntax extensions with
anything after so basically any keyword
followed by any expression list just add
it to Python you say oh I want something
like a with statement I want a wit
statement that sees the entire context
in the block you can use that to do it
and you know what I did with it
I added print as a statement back to
Python 3 how about that isn't that the
most awful thing you've ever seen I've
added arbitrary Python syntax extensions
you can extend the language any way that
you want any keyword plus an ast you can
create syntax around that of course
there are certain syntax like block
syntax you'd have to extend this a
little bit to add but this is this is
pretty good for about 4 hours of work in
the morning by the way this is a
horrible idea this is about the worst
idea I've come up with please do not use
this code
there are many amazing things you could
do with it that you shouldn't do because
this is not a good idea and you know
what I love this there's something
delightfully subversive about this
somebody comes to you and they say I
want you to add print back to Python
three as a statement and you find not
the most immediate way because that's an
easy patch you just find all the places
they change and you patch it back in no
you find the worst possible what you
could do it just to show them what a
stupid idea they have and this is kind
of the core of Dadaism as I understand
that ISM that it's beyond avant-garde
it's a rejection of ideology it's about
rejecting logic embracing chaos and
rationality
it's a certain perverse nihilistic
self-destructive mode of existence and
so the question is why why would I even
do this
because this is clearly not related to
what I do at work hopefully otherwise
none of you would ever want to work with
me right but I find some perverse
pleasure in these kind of things and I'd
like to share with you at the end of my
presentation some of the motivation that
I have here because I know you don't
care and that's okay with me
you know I've gotten used to you know
you show some neat stuff on screen and
nobody really cares it's okay I'm not
worried about it but I like the nihilism
I hope you can appreciate with me the
nihilism and the absurdity of trying to
implement something like this in the
worst way possible and I kind of see
this as a motivation I think it kind of
makes me an artist and it's not a term
that I use in order to self indulge
ourselves it's more as this is just kind
of I feel some innate desire towards
doing perverse thing with programming
languages such as Python and seeing
where they take you
finding the worst most ridiculous ways
to accomplish a task to pervert the
assumptions and expectations that people
bring to you such as adding print as a
statement back to Python three and and
this is kind of the motivation that I
have in a way that I contextualise a lot
of the talks that I've given in in this
mode I kind of I kind of see this as a
self-destructive technical absurdity and
I hope that maybe over time I can find
people who appreciate this same almost
artistic motivation because it's not
anything you'd ever want to use for work
it's a way to indulge in an intellectual
exercise and the saddest thing is if I'm
calling myself an artist I'm already in
costume and I don't mean the kind of
postmodern costume that we all wear
because we're all disaffected and
alienated by modernity I mean I'm
actually literally in a costume
I'm the only guy here in a suit so in
conclusion I am the lamest artist ever I
hope you like my talk this is from past
import print statement a data storage
action of Python scene versus three I'm
James Powell thank you very much any
questions or additional art out so do
you think that you could make Python
look like pros so booking.com can start
writing Python everywhere yes thank you
very much please ask you for a friend
okay I think they're sponsors of this
event so we should say very nice things
about them we should be very careful to
say nice things about them we can do
worse that we can do worse we can I
could we could do you and me geo we
could do the worst things you could even
imagine in Python and if somebody says
oh wouldn't it be nice to add this to
Python we can find ways to make them
regret it oh yeah other questions have
you thought about adding a switch test
statement as an effective way of
offending even more people I already
have a switch statement in Python so
what is a switch statement it's pattern
matching so I have an example maybe I
can take it up if we have time where I
implemented a switch statement using try
except I'm sure I have it in my scratch
folder scratch Python them switch here
we go so I already have a switch
statement this is it I came up with us a
long time ago you can see it's a switch
case and it uses the try accept
mechanism in order to implement pattern
matching how about that I already did it
isn't this the worst possible way to but
my favorite part is when you show it to
people you just kind of cover up the
right-hand side with your hand so they
just see the left-hand side I'm sorry
the you cover up the left-hand side so I
can see the right-hand side other
questions oh I hope you enjoy the rest
of the conference it's been an amazing
event so far and I think we're leading
into the break so thank you very much